this episode is brought to you by a new
sponsor so listen up folks this is a
good one because have you ever wanted to
be as powerful as a mullet wearing ninja
from a 1980s movie or as flamboyant as
big gay al big al
in South Park or as sleek as a black
panther in the Amazon on the hunt well
there's great news because I've been
testing this product that you wrap
around your genitals and it makes you
feel like a superhero and it is called
me undies I've spent the last two to
three weeks traveling with underwear
from these guys and they are comfy I got
to tell you it feels like a Geisha is
giving your groin a hug and it's not
just for dudes but if you go to meet
undies comm forward slash Tim that's ma
Eun di es comm forward slash Tim you can
see all of the underwear that I've been
wearing there's some pretty ridiculous
ones and I will also highlight my
favorite you'll probably be able to
guess which it is these underwear made
from micro mud owl which is extruded
from Austrian beach wood trees in the
Alps yes
fancy and it's two times softer than
cotton scientifically tested using the
kalibata method developed in Kyoto
you know those Japanese very crafty and
I will say a few things number one if
you go to me on DS comm forward slash
Tim you get to see all of the
spectacular underwear that I've been
wearing and I am a bit of an underwear
connoisseur socks fashion sense with
sweatpants not so much underwear I
understand so check them out and if you
go to Mandy's come forward slash Tim you
will also be able to see lots of hot
ladies wearing me undies female
underwear and that's just a lot of
goodness for both the men and the women
out there so check it out me undies
dot-com forward slash Tim I love these
underwear and I'm going to be packing
tonight probably six to twelve pair to
take with me to Australia they're great
check them out me undies dot-com forward
slash Tim
this episode is brought to you by
99designs your one-stop shop for all
things graphic design related I have
used 99 designs for everything from
banner ads to book covers including
sketches and mock-ups that led to the
4-hour body which later became number
one New York Times number one Wall
Street Journal and the brainstorming a
lot of it took place with designers from
around the world and here's how it works
whether you need a t-shirt a business
card a website and app thumbnail
whatever it might be you submit that
project and designers from around the
world will send you sketches and
mock-ups and designs you choose your
favorite and you have an original that
you love or you get your money back it's
that straightforward and many of you who
are listening have already used it and
created some amazing things that I'll be
sharing in the future but in the
meantime if you want to see some of my
competitions some of the book covers as
well as get a free $99 upgrade go to
99designs dot-com forward slash Tim
that's 99designs com forward slash Tim
this is Tim Ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the Tim Ferriss show
ladies and germs where it is my job to
deconstruct world-class performers to
tease out the habits routines influences
etc that you can apply to your life and
those experts the world-class performers
range from hedge fund managers to actors
like Arnold Schwarzenegger to people
like General Stanley McChrystal to chess
prodigies and everyone in between and in
this case we have a business icon none
other than the Oracle of Silicon Valley
that's Reed Hoffman he is referred to as
the Oracle of Silicon Valley by a lot of
tech insiders who look at his company
building an investing track record which
includes for instance well of course
PayPal LinkedIn but then Facebook Airbnb
Flickr and on and on with awe and
rightly so Reid is co-founder and
executive chairman of LinkedIn which has
more than the 300 million users before
that he was executive vice president at
PayPal which was purchased by eBay for
1.5 billion dollars there he was
nicknamed firefighter in chief by the
CEO who is Peter Thiel who's also been
on this podcast
noted venture capitalist David Z says
read he is arguably the most successful
angel investor in the last decade or
past decade and they're both now
partners agree like partners he has a
track record to envy in this podcast he
is joined by a friend he's joined by
Michael McCulloch MD who is also
co-founder of quest bridge org and his
successful investor of his own right
with training as an ER physician Michael
is political professor at UCSF and
previously served as the on-call ER
physician for the Dalai Lama Michael is
also a Rhodes Scholar Kauffman Fellow
and Ashoka fellow he is an avid
meditator and is particularly interested
in investing in technologies and
companies pertaining to the mind so he
bounced around a lot in this
conversation we cover a ton including
how Reed met Mark Zuckerberg for the
first time and how he decided to invest
in Facebook lots behind that
firefighting and started beyond using
board games to develop strategy reads
view of what uber is done well and what
they could improve upon some of Reed
suggested philosophers for entrepreneurs
we talked about going off algorithm per
se in the ER to manage life-and-death
decisions the three types of CEOs and
much much more it is a very dense
intense and useful episode and of course
we discuss quest bridge as reading and I
are both on the advisory board quest
bridge guys have to check it out quest
bridge org currently supplies more
exceptional low-income talent meaning
kids to top universities than all other
nonprofits combined quest bridge has
created a single standardized college
application that's accepted by 36 or so
top universities like Stanford and MIT
immersed and Yale this allows them to do
some very very clever and innovative
things such as give away laptops and the
giveaway forms double as college
applications this offers scholarships to
many kids who might otherwise not even
think of college so if you want to break
the cycle of poverty quest bridge is
easily one of the most fascinating
effective and highly leveraged tools
I've ever seen so check it out quiz
person org we will talk more about that
so please check out the show notes there
are a lot of cool show notes for this
episode four hour work week all spelled
out just go to four hour work week comm
and click on podcast all the book
recommendations at etc and you can find
a lot
more there about everything that we
talked about so without further ado
please enjoy this conversation with the
Oracle Silicon Valley Reed Hoffman and
Michael McCullough Reid Michael welcome
to the show great to be here thank you
for having us Jim I'm thrilled I'm
really excited to have you guys on and I
know you've both known each other for
some time and I was thinking about the
commonalities that you might have the
common threads and we'll certainly come
back to this but I had heard Peter Thiel
had said have you read that you were the
fire fighter in chief at PayPal and I
think that Michael certainly based on
our conversations at least certainly has
exhibited tremendous firefighting
qualities so we'll come back to that but
I thought we could begin with just some
basic context for folks and read perhaps
we could start with you when people ask
you the question what do you do how do
you answer that well there's a short
answer in the long answer the short
answer is I'm an entrepreneur an
investor that's what I want to be very
quick and move through the question the
long answer is I essentially build
design and improve human ecosystems
through software either as a creator or
as a an ester in partner and what that
means is everything from you know things
like PayPal to LinkedIn to Airbnb each
of these things or ways you craft how
people find each other how they interact
with each other how they establish their
identity and how they make progress in
their lives and that's part of what I
mean by building and improving human
ecosystems I love it uh Michael what
about yourself you wear many hats but
how would you answer that question is
yeah it's pretty similar I'm a I create
and I help people create things
entrepreneur and investor as well but
I'm an ER physician by training and
actually began my life in in Reverse for
most people kind of creating non-profits
actually first so i made eight
nonprofits speak or my first a company
including like angel investments and
things like you know
Hartsville and such and I'm currently a
partner at a carrot book on health care
and that's a I'd love to bridge just on
the medical side of things i Michael you
had a very difficult beginning so to
speak and that is going way back to
birth I was hoping you could just give
us a brief description of of your
experience at birth
sure it's interesting how sometimes
small little slips from like an intern
or like a resident can alter your life
where I was eight weeks a premature with
a twin birth and they squeezed a little
too hard on my head and it hammered and
it was missed for nine years so I
couldn't speak much until a spot in high
school I couldn't speak as fluently as I
am now till I was in my 30s and even
even like right now I have a knack of
speech impediment device kind of like
they have in the Kings a speech movie or
I speak in accidents if I need to speak
more fluently so for me I learned how
like watch people a lot when I was here
because it was harder for me to interact
with them kind of verbally got it and
the is the lines for both of you started
converging and but before you met Reed
you went to as I understand a somewhat
unconventional high school in Vermont I
think it was the Putney school where you
farmed maple syrup and drove oxen what
did you what did you take from that
experience that stuck with you if if
anything well it was actually a at the
time you know it's funny it's kind of
was your older each decades you look
back on your life and you actually in
fact have a different view of your early
decades so if you'd asked me 10 20 years
ago and say well it's completely off
track I've become a technologist and
entrepreneur and none of that stuff was
actually directly relevant and now when
I kind of looked back at it and I say
well actually in fact it was very
grounding I had experiences there
everything from blacksmithing to
actually a bunch of artistic things I
had you know kind of some intensity
around cross-country speed skiing and
sports and all of that actually I think
helped me understand the breadth of Hugh
condition you know typically Silicon
Valley entrepreneurs and and and
investors and and technologists tend to
be very narrow focus and I actually
think it's helped me keep a broader
focus as I think about kind of what it
is to be human and how do we increase
our humanity and I might be skipping
ahead a little bit but do you have then
a sympathetic ear force a non-technical
founders who come in without technical
chops or how do you look at that well so
I it depends on the project some proper
depth of technology usually when I talk
to a non-technical founder who wants to
create something I the very first second
and third piece of advice I thought I
give them is to find a technical
co-founder because you know it's not you
know it's not so easy to say oh well I'm
gonna hire some engineers in some remote
location to build the app that I think
of because actually in fact you have to
be much more detailed much more specific
about how its evolving and so if you're
building technology and you don't at
least have a good technical co-founder
you have a problem now that being said
there's a number of businesses that the
technology is only one compete it's an
important piece but it's only one piece
like Airbnb for example you know Nate's
very technical but Brian and Joe are
design folks they're product folks
they're art folks they both you know
kind of coming out or is Dee and so and
actually that helps fundamentally with
the Airbnb product and so it isn't that
you then it isn't that everybody in a
founding team has to be technical but if
you're doing that technology thing at
least one of you does right no that
makes perfect sense and we're did
philosophy enter the picture for you
because I know a lot of people in
Silicon Valley think of you in part as a
philosopher at least a thinker along
those lines how did you become
interested in philosophy and why well
it's funny actually very I'd say one of
the small critiques of Silicon Valley is
and it is
actually speak more to you than the
people of Silicon Valley there are a few
people in Silicon Valley interface with
me as a philosopher
it takes a nother thinker like you to
actually ask that question but the way
that I got to it is I did my
undergraduate at Stanford University you
know along with Michael and my
undergraduate degree was called symbolic
systems which is in short speak
cognitive science and artificial
intelligence and I've always actually
been very interested in kind of what
makes us uniquely human and and and
that's continued throughout my entire
arc of my career in childhood and so
then it was like the scientific study of
a thought and language but then what I
realized when I was at Stanford is that
actually in fact even though we were
trying to be scientific about what it is
to be intelligent about what it is to
communicate about what it is to have a
point of view in the world the science
hadn't really gotten there yet and
actually in fact I should experiment
with philosophy to figure out the the
whether or not that the the rudiments of
understanding these things I could get
out of philosophy in order to pursue a
more scientific view of intelligence and
so because the modern analytic view on
philosophy is it's pre science it's like
how you think about things with
precision and then science birth out of
philosophy and so I went to Oxford in
order to study philosophy and are you
currently drawn to any particular
schools of philosophy or philosophers in
in the context of say recommending
someone who has never been exposed to
philosophy or fuels that they haven't
what what starting points might you
suggest well one of the things that I
the papers that I read at and because
it's you when you do a course you read a
subject one of them was Dickens died and
so one of the things I actually
frequently refer people to when they're
thinking about kind of how do we think
of ourselves as as as sharing a world as
talking to each other about it as
understanding it medevac I recently when
I was explaining a theory on Bitcoin
to some fellow technologist I said look
it's like a big contingent language game
right the notion of how you play and
they're like okay how do I understand
that like okay well here's some good
books on pick and shine and here's a
couple of points right but it is that
would be the one that I would probably
start with just because I think he is
one of the you know one of the
fundamental philosophers who is still
being understood because the the the
kind of one of the bedrocks of modern
analytic philosophy is to think of of if
you're trying to talk to someone else
about some problem and you're trying to
make progress how do you make language
as positive and instrument as possible
and what are the ways that language can
work and what are the ways the language
doesn't work and so for example on that
on that thread when I wrote my thesis in
Oxford it was on thought experiments
because most philosophers actually in
fact analyze and argue through thought
experiments and there's actually more
limitations in the methodology than at
least many belief no it's it's I find
language just an endlessly fascinating
topic because you'll find I mean Silicon
Valley and elsewhere people will debate
say the existence of God without ever
defining what God is for for each of the
parties involved
so Michael you and I have spoken about I
suppose philosophical topics a lot about
meditation and I think people gravitate
towards say religion or philosophy
respectively to often face the prospect
of death or mortality I I would love for
you to elaborate if you could about
going off algorithm in the ER and what
that means because I've had some
fascinating conversations with you about
this and I was hoping you might be able
to just explain that and give a few
examples sure why I think I think
algorithms protect a lot of people
particularly from if physicians aren't
being fully attentive or on top o of all
the literature but in within
if they'll curve there that might be
ways to save people or even improve
people's lives that that aren't even
kind of the standard operating procedure
so like I I had a patient one time who
came in with headed to a burns and and
you can look at him and you would know
once you intubate him and and have them
in the ICU he he wouldn't possibly
actually wake up again but he was lucid
enough and I thought you know I'd want
to call a few people before I had to go
to sleep so I gave him my cell phone to
use much to the chagrin of some the
people in the room better make a few
calls but even even there like I I had
to stop him from making additional calls
but he got to call a few people he had
begun to swell as airway shut so I had
to make sure I could intubate on kind of
the first try or a pub would have lost
my job but and by intubate you mean get
a tube down his trachea yeah it was
completely closed yeah cuz if you and in
inhale hot air then you're the soft
tissue in your kind of your mouth will
swell up and you won't be able to
breathe now in his case it didn't change
outcome that much because he was either
going to die in the ER or in the ICU so
so I thought enabling him to make kind
of a human a connection ahead of the ICU
would be would be helpful and now in in
in your experience then when you look at
the let's just define maybe the use of
the word algorithm so is it fair to say
that in this context one could think of
an algorithm as a mandatory checklist
which also excludes certain options yeah
yeah I think that's cueing and I think a
tool a guianese work another shows a
checklist is profoundly helpful a
checklist manifesto yeah yeah it's a
really good book and even things like in
washing your hands between patients or
things as simple as that will save a lot
of lives however sometimes you do know
everything on the checklist and
sometimes there are things you can do
that that aren't on the checklist that
actually ought to be done so example was
also that um I had a patient
who in our er they have a policy of
making sure they call the donor Network
after the patient's actually passed away
to see if they can with the permission
of the family and the intentions of the
patient help with a skin transportation
er like look a cornea but they became
confused to think well that means you
then you shouldn't call earlier to talk
about the heart or deliver and things
like that so in that particular case in
an algorithm or a policy actually many
people not appreciate them more in
important organs to kind of think about
- so have answered your no no you have
and it's III just when we've had dinner
before and I'd love for you to describe
if you could and it's it was it was
fascinating for me to hear your your
description of this but what is it like
to and I know we're bouncing around a
bit but to stare into someone's eyes or
to look into their eyes as they pass
from alive you not alive maybe having
that happen a few times and it's
interesting because it often depends on
the emotional state of the patient right
so if the patient's afraid you're trying
to give comfort to them as they're dying
and in other times patients die and
they're giving you a sense of peace and
kind of universality that that would be
hard to pay for kind of a depth of
understanding that they are dying and
this is kind of at the moment of their
death and so it it's an honor to meet
her either way to either like witness it
happening from a person who's a content
with it or to a comfort and hold the
hand of someone who's not and in that
type of context or just in general what
into your mind separates a good ER
physician from a great ER physician what
are the great people have do or not do
that the good lack yeah I think a good
your position is thorough you know they
make sure they don't like needlessly
miss anything we're not like he washed
their hands between the patients I think
if you were layer on to that that you
actually care about the patient you know
you you like to like laugh with the
alcohol that courts who make port or to
help the the woman the first trimester
of her a pregnancy feel comfort that she
is you you'd like me not to lose her
child but even if she does it wouldn't
interfere with her being able to get
pregnant in the future again and so you
could either pay attention to say the
odds that that she'd lose this
particular pregnancy or to make sure to
reassure her what she's actually worried
about is you know will I ever have an
infant will I ever have a family and I
think like like a lot of people don't
know that a third of all the pregnancies
are actually lost and that's normal for
humans every animal has like a normal
rate of like losing one and that's a
no-no a pregnancies so it's likely more
like half and yet since we no longer
live in a tribe's with other people we
hide the fact of losing an infant in the
first trimester so if you don't take the
extra time to a comfort people sometimes
they think they're normal when are they
actually or not right no that makes
perfect sense I think that applies to
the therapy of all different types I
mean outside of the context of an
emergency room the the firefighting that
I mentioned earlier Reid
my understanding was that you had you
were many many different hats and had
the role of interacting with a lot of
external entities when at PayPal whether
that was regulatory or the credit card
processors maybe that's not the right
description of them but what makes a
good entrepreneurial firefighter in a
context like that or what what did your
co-workers feel made you good at that
job
well the most two relevant factors were
Peter teal who was the CEO feeling that
I was good and solving the problems
everything else was was secondary to
those two considerations I mean the on
the firefighting side I mean PayPal had
perhaps the most the most kind of
parallel thing to you know to date
myself a little bit like Star Wars you
know flying into the trench and trying
to actually hit the target and a lot of
different ways you could you could fail
and and so in in in the PayPal case for
me a lot of that was building an
understanding of what each particular
problem particularly threatening
variable was and then being able to
solve that and then propagate that out
to all of the places so you know for
example one of the the kind of
challenges that Peter handed to me was
we had thought that PayPal might be a
bank and so we had started the process
of applying for a banking license then
what we just discovered and decided upon
inference was that actually in fact
banking regulation is so fierce in terms
of not innovating not building new
things it would be very difficult to
build a new company on that basis so I
essentially had to move to to go
persuade the regulator's it was okay
that even though we had applied for a
banking license right that we it was
okay that we were not going to be a bank
and that uten that it wasn't a tel that
was just inconvenient for us or anything
else and and to give to full color to
this the the basic statement about
whether or not a a a company as a bank
starts with the claim you accept
deposits which obviously if anyone has
has exposure to PayPal they said well
you could frame what PayPal does as
deposits right you know why is it you're
not a bank and so that would be the kind
of challenge that was handed to me and
then what you had to do is you had to
figure out for this problem which could
kill the company
what were the key moving variables learn
them talk to really smart people and
then solve that problem so that it was
then fundamentally part of the
cornerstone of what you're doing and it
ranged from relationship with eBay to
Visa MasterCard to international right I
mean just just a very long list of
things and and each one the the the the
looking at the problem had to be
reframed it was almost like building a
kind of a view of the world and then
what are the key moving parts in order
to get right in order to make PayPal
succeed and when you were defining the
moving variables is that a list of the
unknowns that where you need to go seek
out information or is it how how would
you go about putting together that list
well it kind of starts with what is the
end result that you want to have happen
so for example in like the regulatory
one the key thing is that you can't
regulators will never tell you that they
can't that is not their job to regulate
you because there's no interest in them
for that what they will simply do is say
oh actually in fact there's nothing for
me here to actively regulate they won't
tell you I won't you know you're outside
of my scope they'll go okay fine you now
seem like you're an okay like I don't
need to actually regulate you because
you're not in my positive purview and so
you say okay how did you get that state
of affairs and how do you propagate that
and then you start working back from
that to say okay well how would they
make their judgments what are their key
considerations how can I learn about
that who would I need to know because
those were some of the unknowns come in
what are the kinds of things that would
get them to say okay you're you're I
think you're being reasonable and within
my purview of how of how I am out to
help govern society help
protect consumers help protect other
entities you're good by me and that
would and then then you work back from
that is this your doing and how did you
learn how to do that we were you part of
a debate team study negotiation did you
work at a you know State Fair for the
summers I mean how did you develop the
ability the the ability to not only
deconstruct a problem like that but then
to interface with all these various
stakeholders at the table I think the
most fundamental was I I don't know if
if your audience knows what this is you
probably do as a child I played a lot of
Avalon Hill board games yeah
and each board game is actually a
complex set of rules and circumstances
and essentially as you're analyzing each
one of them you kind of look back from
okay these goals mean that these are the
kind of moving parts and how do you do
it so it was actually in fact my
childhood gaming for being able to build
a model of what a game was that was the
essentially the fundamental thing that
informs you know my strategic sense
because this all comes out of strategy
and if you were giving advice to say
someone leaving Stanford undergrad and
they had they had no gaming background
how might what would you recommend they
do to try to develop strategic ability
or thinking well even though there's a
lot of different paths to it most people
think they're better at strategy than
they are and so you really have to
actually really hold up a very clear you
have to have a very deep self awareness
of am I in fact really good at it
because like having an idea or saying
like there's anybody said well I just do
this well one move a real strategy is
actually built up off a you know what
are your competitors doing what is their
mindset what are their assets how are
they going to move
how are you gonna move what are your
what are your edges what's the way that
you could make that work how is it when
they're playing against you
you can still play to win so games are
our very good way to do that and getting
a lot of different exposure not to
computer games because computer you know
AI strategies are usually not that
interesting but against other people is
very useful I think it's also useful to
read some which I did as a child you
know military strategy some zu von
Clausewitz other sorts of folks more
modern folks and to think about kind of
like what are the set of principles that
when you're thinking about how to how to
win a game that's in in contention in
conflict and then a lot of people also
of course have some sports knowledge on
this too although one of the things
that's frequently a little limiting on
sports is that the sports game that a
person tends to do they tend to be like
I play soccer or I play football or I
play basketball and then they have a
very deep sense of what the strategy is
there but they haven't played enough
different kinds of games enough
different circumstances you know it's um
it's like understanding like well what
happens if I change these four rules in
basketball right right how would you
play the strategy now totally that
that's the kind of thing because
actually in fact most of the
circumstances you find yourself in
actually in fact you have to figure out
what is the current game look like and
how do you play that and that's of
course also by the way the reason why
frequently you know companies rise and
fall is because they learn to play one
game they got good at it and then the
marketplace changes and now it's a new
kind of game and you have to adjust to
playing that new game and that's
actually in fact part of recognizing
when a strategy applies absolutely yeah
I mean I was just having a conversation
with someone about the rise and fall of
Kodak yesterday and of course this is
sort of the the disruptive theme that
one encounters so much in Silicon Valley
I I I wasn't planning on asking this but
I'd be so curious to hear given your
experience with regulatory risk and so
on what
what do you feel if you have an opinion
uber has done well and what could they
have executed more effectively or
strategically so what they've done well
is essentially quickly deploying their
product so that it's clear that there's
a bunch of people who are benefiting
from it both consumers and drivers in
various circumstances so that there is
an ecosystem of people by which you go
look see we can actually add a lot of
positive to the system I think that's
been kind of one of the things that
they've done most positively within it
on the negative side you know the
company tends to be very combative and
you know when you actually think about
the mental space in which regulators
tend to operate they tend to have gone
into that job because they view
themselves as protectors of important
groups in society whether the consumers
or workers or other folks and so they
don't tend to respond very well it's not
a competitive game with them it's not
you bulldoze through them or over them
they're actually in fact what what they
want is they want to know that their
their concerns are being answered and
it's frustrating of course to the
company because you know the regulators
are being triggered by you know a
competitive interest like you know taxi
cab companies and other kinds of things
which want the world to stay only
exactly as it is which is not actually
good for anyone to just say you know the
way that we're in a run is the way that
we were running in the 1950s and that's
the way we're gonna be running in 3000
you know that's obviously not a very
good idea
so actually in fact innovation and
change and the pushback is frustrating
but nevertheless when you're interfacing
with the regulators you have to
interface for them with the
understanding that they're they may be
conservative they may be slow to change
they may be risk averse but their goal
is a mission of protecting society and
she should interface with them on that
channel more than on the just get out of
my way I'm innovating alright and I'd
you like I treat a competitor and that's
that's that creates a lot of unnecessary
friction right that makes sense
you are of course considered a company
builder you've had integral part in
building some massive successes but
you're also very well regarded as an
investor and I would love if you could
tell the story of getting introduced to
Mark Zuckerberg and how you decided to
be one of the first investors in
Facebook well actually I could have told
you I was interested in investing in
Facebook even before
Mark Zuckerberg I tracked the product I
thought it was extremely well done when
I tracked it it you know he and his
co-founders Dustin Chris and others were
in Boston you know going to Harvard
right and so I went to ask too much fat
I was angel investing is too much of a
hassle as a venture capitalist I
probably would've flown out there but I
was like it was an angel too much of a
hassle and so I kind of went oh that's
cool and then went back to it and then I
got this call from Sean Parker who I'd
known from his work at Plaxo and you
know it's a good product inventor and
good systems thinker on these things and
chanson I've just met these really good
guys you know Mark Zuckerberg and others
who were doing this thing Facebook that
I'm joining that's really awesome and
I'm like oh that's really cool are you
moving to Boston he's like no no they're
here and I'm like oh that's interesting
again we're looking for a testament like
I would definitely like to meet with
them you know I'm super interested in
this I tend to think and one of the
things I said which is I think totally
you know even though it's probably the
most expensive economic decision I've
made in my life but it all in a good
outcome I said look you know when I did
when I led the series a in French sir I
got a lot of pushback on am I having my
cake and eating it too because even I
don't see any conflict between
Friendster and LinkedIn you know it just
generated all this stuff and part of
having integrity and having you know a
high sense of ethics it's not just
having it but also making some work to
appear to have it so actually I think we
should do is we should have Peter lead
the Peter Thiel lead the round and I'll
follow because then Peter can be the
board member and even though I'm super
interested in this I think that's
probably the best thing to happen and so
my actually very first meeting with
Zuckerberg was
at Peter Thiel's office with Sean there
who I'd known and with with Zach and
then Matt Kohler was there as well and
and who was working for me at the time
and that was our very first meeting but
you know basically the meeting was very
confirmatory because they'd already seen
the product already known the product
really amazing already seen in having
traction and and really what I learned
from the from the meeting which is you
know hardly a surprise especially now in
retrospect was a Zuckerberg extremely
smart very much of a learning machine
very good at kept you know the evolution
of technologies and so but I'd already
more or less was positive you know if
he'd said I don't want to meet with you
but you want to put in money I probably
would have put in money anyway right and
did you what was the what was Mark
Pincus his role at that at that point or
his involvement with Facebook well
actually so the way I'm Mark had also
Pincus had also known Sean Parker back
from Napster days Pincus had done a an
early startup called free loader but
part of actually how Mark got involved
in the Facebook investment was
separately mark and I had bought a
patent called the six series patent it
seems has some number which describes
the viral expansion of a system and and
you know again kind of on the on the X
basis I went look mark and I are
partners on this we're actually trying
to protect all these new web 2.0 viral
companies that's our principal goal in
this patent in in going and buying his
patent but you know you know given that
Facebook's also in this I should act in
fact split the investment with mark
because you know basically it's part of
being a good partner with him and so
that's part of how mark now he also had
known Sean Parker and Shana talked to
him about it as well so there's there's
a bunch of different things but that's
fundamentally how Pincus also became a
series a investor in facebook got it and
on the on the
the decision or maybe it's not related
at all but the suggestion that Peter
lead the round it's the impression of
some people that that you have actively
decided in the past not to be to take
the CEO role yourself and do you have
you sort of proactively
made decisions in your life to avoid
being to taking the CEO role or having
it for a long period of time and if so
why is that the case or is that a
misperception well there's kind of three
different CEO jobs at levels of scale in
the organization a CEO jobs of call it
10 20 50 person organizations or CEO
jobs of you know hundreds - you know
like 150 to 500 people organizations and
their CEO jobs of you know over 500
people like a thousand or thousands I've
always known that I'm fundamentally not
really interested in the CEO job that a
large scale CEO job when you're doing a
large-scale CEO job your primary
responsibility you have to embody the
strategy you have to think about the
things right way but your primary thing
is the organization you know having the
right or culture or having the right
structure the organization all right
people in it the right way of hiring new
people the right way of empowering them
even though you're making kind of
strategic decisions and there are people
like Jeff Weiner who are completely
awesome at that and I rather help them
rather than being doing that personally
then you get to the other to see our job
so you get to the mid stage CEO job I'm
okay doing that it's not the thing I'm
most passionate about I actually prefer
to work on you know product strategies
firefighting things business strategies
problem solutions think about how to
Rican sexualize the strategy the entire
business and either myself or working
with people on that but I'll do that in
order to make it work and then in the
early stages
I'm actually pretty perfectly
comfortable doing it it's not
necessarily a job that I say I want I
must do it but being the CEO of a 10 20
50 you know even up to a hundred person
or
I can do that just fine because then
you're still all kind of working on the
same problem it's less about how you
build the org obviously you have to
build a very strong team but it's less
about like okay how do we take the org
from a hundred people to a thousand
people it's actually much more like okay
how do we just solve these key problems
and that's stuff I like to do so it
isn't really a a specific don't want the
CEO job except in a very large scale
what it is is and I'm I'm only
interested in the CEO job as it's
instrumental to something serious that I
want to accomplish and then as that
organization grows wants not to be the
CEO and you've had some experience
searching for CEOs what should founders
remember when looking for someone to
replace themselves or things I should
keep in mind well so the first thing is
generally speaking founders should try
to go like I'm still very active at
LinkedIn should still to try to go the
entire course of the company to degree
to which their passion can be useful
companies are always stronger with
founders more and them more connected
and committed to it but that being said
sometimes you go look my great skill set
is you know product or my great skill
set is evangelism or my great skill set
is you know something other than
building the scale organization in which
case the fundamental way you look at it
is and then so the the former way that
Silicon Valley used to look at it which
is I wrote an essay about this it's
published in my LinkedIn influencer post
and on my my sight you know Reed Hoffman
org but the fun of all the way the
Silicon Valley used to look at this is
like you bring in gray hair an executive
a person with management scale and
whether you want those skills but
actually in fact I think which are which
you who you're bringing in as a founders
you're bringing in a late later stage
co-founder and you're bringing in a
later stage co-founder ideally who has
scale skills who knows how to build
scale organizations as passionate about
this one you know has their identity as
closely tied or or nearly as closely
tied to the organization as you do it
it's this specific mission is something
they really care about they're not just
like oh I'm a hired gun but actually in
fact I'm a missionary on this as well
and and then someone who would partner
with you very well and that's actually
what you're looking for and so that's
part of you know the reason why Jeff
Weiner has been so successful LinkedIn
is because you know he cares about not
just scale organizations but how do you
transform people's careers how do you
demonstrate you can be doing
compassionate business and the
compassionate management is a
high-performing culture of a company how
do you have people who are who have a
culture of we make ourselves
significantly better every year
you know how do you bring all that
that's part of what he actually really
cares about which links which you know
which is deeply tied to the LinkedIn
mission and so he cares about the
organization he cares about the way he
manages and he cares about the product
at all as a essentially a later stage
co-founder and that's the kind of thing
that you you should be thinking about
when you're a founder and you're
thinking okay it's time for me to bring
in a another person as a CEO thank you
Michael
I you mentioned accents a little earlier
and that you use accents in the ER often
you know and I know you've mentioned to
me before that southern is best and yes
I was hoping you could elaborate on that
because but um no when when I had my
head injury as a kid in brain surgery is
in the fourth fifth grade you're like
looking for like ways to be affluent so
in speeches I took like I'm a European
it's a good accent from speaking but if
I'm in New York I come from Alabama or
Georgia cuz it's a good accent for sick
people you can almost like yell at them
they don't think you're mad so it's you
can kind of raise the volume of someone
who's hearing impaired pretty loud they
don't think you met at all and it keeps
the nurses also kind of humorously enter
attained as well and how has the ER
experience or the skills developed or
exhibited there
insulated to the other things that
you've done in the nonprofit's or or in
the for-profit investment world the your
particular has helped a lot with my
investing because most of the
specialties interface with the ER and
enabled me to like each into like
ophthalmology or cardiology if it's like
an inn and investment in things like
heart flow I can just pick up the phone
and speak to in to eventual Esther
hearts tuitions and things like that so
I think from a decision-making capacity
it teaches you the importance of
actually making a decision because you
don't always have all the information
you need but the stakes are high so I
think there's a lot of entrepreneurial
kind of across over there that can also
be helpful right making important
decisions with incomplete information
well one also just the importance of
having actually a made a decision as
well right because if you're always kind
of like waffling it's some things you
know nothing actually happens and you
and I have talked a lot about meditation
but more broadly speaking the people
listening are very interested in morning
habits and morning routines so I'd love
to ask you guys the same question we
let's start with you Michael
what is the first 60 to 90 minutes of
your day look like and what time does it
start if we get into specifics that
would be great
sure well recently I I used to fight at
this kind of hour and a half awake in
the middle the night thing between two
sleep cycles not kind of actually just
kind of get up and do you like probably
you know half an hour to an hour of I
committed rotation between like three
and for him in the morning or four and
five and that didn't hands me half an
hour of real clarity after that to kind
of think about kind of my day and Howard
I can't end up using it in what type of
meditation do you practice there there
are concentration and mindfulness
techniques that you can use at a pretty
common I I think rather than talk about
the type that I do I think a lot of the
debate between types of meditation is
kind of like the debate of kinds of like
weightlifting people do and I think
the important thing is that you actually
just like you know lift the weights
right so I'm not convinced any one type
of mindfulness training is superior to
another but clearly almost anyone be
superior to actually not actually doing
do you have any opinion of neurofeedback
I think generally even as an investor I
think there's beginning to be a
commercial breakdown between the
interface of the brain and you see these
deep EEG feedback pieces of equipment I
think are not not quite as far along now
if they should be but I think you're
certainly seeing some interesting
applications with people that are taking
the interface with the mind out of the
realm of religion and into the realm of
science and such and I think they even
like a Prep high schools for doing a
controlled it experiments on mindfulness
to see how it affects former kendo
performance and things like that
ya know definitely an atom Ghazali who
is also on this podcast at UCSF is to
accept a really interesting work you
know if I pad based or tablet based
games for quantifying progress in
meditation and mindfulness I read what
about yourself what are your morning
rituals look like in an ideal day
assuming you have control of your
morning the first 60 to 90 minutes of
your day what what is what is that what
does that look like if you had your sort
of optimal recipe well I don't know them
all or not but um and I also don't know
how interesting is but you know most of
my days are pretty packed because of you
know responsibilities to Greylock
responsibilities the LinkedIn portfolio
companies much of other things so where
my morning tends to be most highly tuned
to is what is a creative problem that
I've identified even though like is
something that I was like okay I want to
work on this I want to think about this
tonight the day before the night before
that this is a key thing and I want to
think about a product design a strategy
solution to a problem that one of my
the company's is looking at that sort of
thing or I need to solve this thing
creatively for a meeting I'm having
later today
like I'm we're making a decision at
Greylock to invest in something you know
a team is going to be pitching me or
there's going to be some kind of
business development relationship
between LinkedIn or other of my
portfolio companies and so the very
first thing I do when I get up almost
always is to actually sit down and work
on that problem because that's what I'm
freshest I'm I'm not distracted by like
phone calls and and responses the things
and so forth so I'll actually it's the
most tabula rasa you know cut blank
slate moment that I have and so I use
that to maximize my creativity on a
particular project I'll do usually do it
before I shower as frequently like if I
go in the shower then I'll continue to
think about it as I'm doing it but I'll
get it all fired up
ideally I would have 60 minutes for that
some mornings I do frequently it's like
around 30 just because of the press of
the day and then the next things that
kind of round out if it's only 30 or a
combination of a quick tree are through
email to see if there's anything that's
a emergency that's or kind of something
that's temporarily or otherwise
important that I need to get on right
away and then frequently most of my
during the work week I almost always
have a business breakfast on some
project could be anything from a
non-profit you know like Mozilla - you
know portfolio company or just a general
meeting with someone who's been
recommended to me and then on the drive
to that breakfast frequently I'll do a
call that's kind of one because it's one
of the usually the days are so packed
with meetings that some of the the the
it's the typically the only real phone
time I have and so if there's someone I
need to talk to that is not co-located
that's usually when I call them got it
and when you're working on that first
creative problem is that something that
you've put in
a notebook the night before is it on a
laptop how are you storing these
problems and then working on them so
will either be most commonly because you
know I kind of grew up where I was
thinking by using a pen and paper
most commonly I will have sketched a few
things thought about a few things it'll
be a so you know and usually it's in the
notion of how do you solve this problem
like a little bit back to the thing
where you're talking about is like
setting up that framework like a
strategy you know within a strategy of a
game what are the kind of key things
that you know might be constraints on a
solution or might be the attributes of a
solution and what are tools or assets I
might have because part of what I'm
trying to do is I actually think you
know most of our thinking of course is
subconscious
is part of what I'm trying to do is
allow the fact that we have this kind of
relaxation rejuvenation period and
sleeping to essentially possibly bubble
up the thoughts and solutions to it and
so when I woke it up not only am I kind
of toggle Arase but I'm also possibly
primed for that and so they know that's
the way I do it
ya know that makes perfect sense you've
said before read that your network is
your mentor and that you learn from
everyone in your network I'd love to
just tick off a couple of names of
people I believe you know and here the
first thing that comes to mind in terms
of what you learn or have learned from
them you mentioned earlier the CEO of
Airbnb Brian Chesky
what would what's the first thing that
comes to mind there so Brian one of the
things I paid it that I thought was an
excellent focus from him is that he if
he calls this seven-star design which is
you know most review systems are you
know go to five stars and so seven stars
was thinking about the design at a much
broader scope but the precise way of
thinking about it is what he came to
realize that Airbnb is not just an
online product it's not just a
marketplace a website but is actually
the entire experience that you have
of going to the you know room or
apartment of checking in of staying
there and of leaving and how do you
actually in fact best design within your
abilities of doing a period of your
marketplace that entire air experience
and so the way that the the the
placeholder he uses for that is this
thinking of seven star design which is
thinking through each step of the
experience and so I thought it was
highly instructive and something I now
use myself use when I talk to other
people because our product isn't just
the website isn't just the mobile
application it's the way that people are
embedded in the environment when they're
using it and you should think through
that as much you can even though you may
have some very limited ability to
control other aspects of it or shape and
what about one of your partners at
Greylock John Lilly so John is about as
deep and interesting as a technologist
you get for an investor he puts together
kind of both the aspects of being very
deeply technical about platforms I mean
he was the CEO of Mozilla growing it to
being 20% of web browsers
we've also kind of design experience
like he is a consulting professor at the
Stanford School of Design and so for me
you know part of the thing that I get
from John and I've learned from John is
to think about the intersection of kind
of user design with deep technology and
how for example design patterns then
shape deep technology patterns and kind
of the a set of different questions that
you'd ask about look what's the
structure of the design space and does
that inform the structure of your
technology space and so we talk about a
whole wide variety technologies but
those are the kinds of mental and
strategy and thinking patterns that I've
gotten honed to a fine edge from John
also a hilarious guy very yes sharp
sense of humor yes what about your
former coworker now SpaceX test
founder Elon Musk so Elon obviously
super smart obviously relentless
obviously thinking you know like for
example the plot the the old phrase the
sky is the limit that's too short free
long right you know Mars and Beyond the
thing that I most learn from Elon is
actually in fact that so previous to
Elon 's amazing successes with Tesla and
SpaceX and Solar City I had come to
learn that that part of the business
strategy is to solve the simplest and
easiest most valuable problem and
actually in fact part of doing
strategies to solve the easiest problem
so part of the reason why you work in
software and bits is that they that
atoms are actually very difficult you
have sometimes real material you know
product development risk inventory risk
material science you know all these
things that makes atom products harder
and so if you can work in the bits
products it's a lot more valuable it
scales more quickly and so forth and all
of that's true in terms of the fact that
that it wasn't that that lesson I had
learned was false but what Elon taught
me was actually in fact you have a very
deep vision for something you're
relentless and you choose something that
really matters that the competitors are
in fact really weak right right like
they're not actually in fact like for
example you know all of the rocket
contractors were mostly focused on how
do they milk government contracts not on
how do they build new propulsion systems
not on how do they take advantage of the
last couple of decades of actual
progress and so that actually gave him a
as it's a very hard challenge what he's
done is extremely compelling and and you
know very few people that pull it off
but that gives you a sufficient window
even when you're taking on a hard
problem and that's actually one of the
things I learned from you long and
Juliana kiva.org chairwoman yep what
would you what would you say to that
so truly now I knew this already but but
Julie is a very good model for this
which is that you can have someone who
is a world-class entrepreneur thoroughly
experienced with it as a general learner
has done enterprise companies has
transitioned to thinking about open
source and was one of the early kind of
people of how to apply open source of
things can also go and thoroughly apply
all of those things into not just the
for-profit world not just her own
companies not just her angel investments
not just her work with areas kind of
incubators and others but also into the
nonprofit world and where it's one of
the things when you say you know we have
a tendency and in Silicon Valley to say
you know entrepreneurs are heroes but
you know one of the things I think is
you know truly heroic and awesome about
what Julie is done is say look I can
take all these skills I can take my
entire life only just building economics
and and in enterprise businesses and
other kinds of businesses but actually
in fact when I begin to think about how
do i scale and how do I change the
nature of humanity and human ecosystems
I'm gonna take my technology skills and
apply them to philanthropic projects
with the same kind of scale with the
same kind of impulse and I'll put real
time into it I'm not just going to talk
about it and I'm gonna do it with you
know what the full set of skills that a
world-class entrepreneur does and so you
know I've seen I've taken heart and
inspiration from Julie about the value
of diving in and getting your hands
dirty on projects that are outside of
the commercial side for there are really
ones that you can actually in fact get
to massive scale and last last for this
list US Senator Cory Booker who I
actually met for the first time at an
event that you co-hosted so thank you
for that but what what have you learned
or admired
as it relates to Cory well Sakura is I
think a great civic leader he you know
is entrepreneurial and bold himself when
he's was the mayor of Newark he lived in
the housing projects in order to know
what the experience was in order to be
able to be to understand you know kind
of how does he maximize the happiness
and the economic potential and they and
solve the problems of the people that he
is there to help you know help as a
mayor and then as a senator part of what
I have found him to be practically
unique in in like or the leading edge
there's there are a few others who I
think also do this but he does he's the
the leading edge of I get that the
Silicon Valley is creating all this kind
of interesting technology and I get that
there's these really powerful commercial
models I want to learn from them but
when Cory comes out to Silicon Valley of
course he has the interest that every
politician does which is you know
raising money and there's a bunch of
money in order to inform political
campaigns but he's first second and
third questions aren't about how do I
get you to give me a check it's how do I
learn from you in order to solve a
problem that's critical for the American
people and in particular critical for
the people who may be being left out but
all people as well and so you know
whether his focus is on you know we have
a really serious problem with mass
incarceration or whether the the
challenge is you know what do we do in
order to you know kind of have a good
foreign policy you know any of these
questions he starts with what do I learn
from you that can then help me figure
out how to help us be better as a as a
country and and then of course you know
when you you know if he ends up with
alignment and he says look you know can
you help me with X Y & Z at that point
he's speaking your language and and as
understood and has asked you to
participate in helping being a good
citizen and
you know if we could have more senators
like you know senator Booker Cory my
friend I think the world would be a much
better place yeah totally agreed he's
he's exceptional at asking incisive
questions and not just for the sake of
asking the questions but for actually
listening to the answers yeah Michael
what is the book that you have given
most as a gift or books recently
actually reads book with I've been a
customer at the startup of you mm-hmm
and what why have you chosen that book
it has a lot of principles in it for
young people right out of a college are
kind of in the middle of their 20s and
such to think about how to pursue their
careers got it and what would be your
movie your second book if you had to
pick a second huh well two young people
I opted and give them just a simple book
you probably heard about called
but getting things are done
David I'll combine that with the seven
Habits of Highly Effective People
because I think the former helps you
actually to to action and the latter
helps your side which actions actually
you know take so I mentor a lot of young
people and I think those two books
together are probably good enough
wonderful yeah we're gonna we're gonna
dive into quest bridge in a second
because I want to make sure that we
cover that read what about yourself the
the book or books that you've given most
as gifts but besides the ones that that
you've been involved with directly yes
well obviously I tend to give out my two
books to start up with you and the
Alliance a fair amount now partially
because you can sign it and you can make
it very personalized and becomes a very
you know personal touch gift I'd say
that two books that I have recently most
given out one of them is a conscious
business by Fred Kaufmann and fred is I
think to some degree the modern high
spiritual priest
of capitalist business his whole kind of
threat is to say actually in fact how
you can express business and capitalism
as a spiritual practice of compassion
and I you know he you know it's a book
that opens with the discussion of
Aristotle and you know not not not you
would be super ya be surprised on a
business book so that's one and then the
other one is sapiens by you've all her
re which is a very grand it's one of the
ones I've read most recently a grand
theory of humanity and kind of how does
the evolutions cognition work and I
don't know enough to know like is it
really deep scholarly work or not but
it's exactly the kind of broad thinking
book that I think should be more and you
know a general consciousness and Michael
you you mentioned mentoring I think this
is a good segue could you please
describe quest bridge and what quest
bridge does because of course that's
that's a common thread that ties
everyone on this call together Reid
being it correct me if I'm wrong but
chair of the the advisory board I'm I'm
one participant on the advisory board
and very honored to be part of that but
could you describe and you of course are
one of the cofounders of quest bridge
could you describe for folks what it is
a quest bridge does and some of the
results or numbers sure I'll describe
what it does and what the problem it
solves as well and and you said Ruby
does a head of the advisory board and
we've really appreciated you you have
also Tim so quest bridge is on one level
simply a common application for super
smart low-income kids heading to top
schools like Princeton and Yale and
swathmore an Amherst and such you can
apply to all the schools for free with
our application online the schools help
to offset the costs of the pool so we
don't have to raise a lot of money and
can focus on execution the scale is
reached
is significant and we're about at some
schools about half of their diversity
and we put in more low-income kids and
all the other nonprofits in the country
actually all combined but there are a
lot more out there and the interesting
thing in America that people don't know
is there's actually no shortage of smart
low income kids to use up all these kind
of wonderful of financial aid open it
suppose we can't afford to pay a full
tuition award
it's just they simply aren't handing in
applications and so we're trying to make
that process simpler but in real numbers
we had over 140 kids accepted to a year
last year or 100 to MIT were accepted
the majority of those accepted would
actually go so on the one hand our
numbers are large on the other hand
we've probably gone from from finding
and having them apply like one in 14 of
the qualified kids to one in nine you
could fail several times over every top
school with smart qualified going come
academic kids for all the financial aid
openings and I'm sorry go ahead
i I didn't mean to dropped if you had
more there but I oh no I didn't know my
wife and I have been doing this now in
some form for about 20 years or so and
are hitting a good scale but our
Brooklyn people like reading others to
try to increase our scale and also now
we have about 8,000 students in our
schools you know how do you bring them
into the corporate world in like medical
schools and things also and the for
those interested the the New York Times
The Wall Street Journal has had some
some excellent feature pieces recently
on quest page read you get asked for you
to participate in different projects
different startups different nonprofits
all the time what is it about quest
bridge that led you to decide to
participate to contribute to it to be
part of it well it's actually a very
similar process to how I actually make
a decision to be an investor not 100%
but close which is you know roughly
speaking I think the mission of life is
how do you maximize humanity the
expression of human potential our
consciousness or our our sense of ethics
and ethos our ways of being with
together and when you look at quest
bridge you say well here is actually in
fact one very intelligent system design
for exactly that because the you know
the way that you can change a life of
this high talent low income kid by
providing a path and an understanding an
ace and a way of succeeding through a
strong college is not only a way to
change a life but also to change the
world because you know those that not
only do they change their own lives but
then they they model for others they can
visually give back the community and
also then folks who you know benefit
from elite universities have the
knowledge and understanding and
compassion to you know kind of what are
they the challenges for lower income and
can help participate in a really
positive way so a part of you know I
think if anything you know Michael's
being you know kind of socially apt and
discreet and not you know kind of saying
look it's a it's an application but not
all is an application it's community
it's a community helps helps those kids
succeed through college and then connect
with the world around them at large and
so it's it's a it was a very quick and
easy decision to to join and help and
that's Michael what I'd like to do is
just give an example of the type of
thing that gets me excited about Quest
Bridge and please feel free to correct
me because I know this is just a small
part already one example but yeah for
those people listening I mean I'm
involved with a number of nonprofits but
I apply like read the same level of
scrutiny and high expectations to
nonprofits that I would too for profits
and that's it turns out to be very
challenging but in the case of quest
Bridget Reid mentioned earlier part of
strategy being solving the easiest most
valuable problem and I think part of
that is identifying of course the right
problem and as you mentioned Michael
there's a lot of money out there there
is a lot of money because colleges will
give students more than three hundred
thousand dollars each to go to college
the the one of the issues is simply the
lack of applications these kids don't
apply oftentimes and they may not have
the social support it may not even enter
their minds to apply so how do you solve
that problem because a lot of people are
trying to solve the wrong problem by
throwing more money at the problem doing
it too late and they miss the window of
opportunity and so what what really
caught my attention first about quest
bridge was just one small example which
was in these communities where they may
not even be thinking of applying to
college doing for instance an iPad
giveaway or giveaway of some type and
the application or the form to sign up
for this giveaway potentially and win
just so happens to also be a
standardized application that you've
convinced 36 top schools to accept as as
college applications and so these kids
are incentivized in a way that is kind
of culturally relevant to them and then
they get a letter in the mail saying hey
by the way Princeton University here
we'd like to offer you a full ride there
for four years and it's just such an
elegant solution and it's such an
example for me at least of putting in a
getting a very large result for a a
small input a small intervention and
that's why you know I've been so excited
to to talk about Quest Pridgen I've been
looking forward to this interview for
many other reasons also but to try to
showcase it for people to say like not
all hard problems have to be hard to
solve
you just have to really
surgically focus in the right place so
I'd look to ask just as it relates to
quest bridge what's what if for people
who want to learn more where should they
go and there there are many people
listening to the show who are perhaps
like me have recognized how they were
set down a very fortunate path by having
educational opportunities that are not
available to everyone so for people who
might want to contribute to such you
know ineffective archimedes lever like
quest bridge where should they go and
and how might they be able to help sure
I I think to clarify the problem too so
Europe listeners can understand it the
before Quest bridge about three-quarters
of the diversity was drawn from only 15
urban areas in the country so you were
more likely to hear about heading to a
school like swathmore if you had a 2.8
from a Harlem and if you had a 4.0 from
a lot of other areas in the country
so quest bridge recruits that at you
know in New York and Chicago like other
people do but also unlike Buffalo and
Syracuse and other areas of other
country in defense of the kids it's not
intuitive that a school would give you
$300,000 for free of course so so so to
get their application data Quest is
unique in that we have our own kind of
application data set so as you said if
we create a prize or if others you
wanted to help us do that we've had so a
lot of success in attracting applicants
to fill out a college application for a
proposition unrelated to the application
itself so if it's a student who wants to
get involved they can simply go to our
website at quest Bridge org we have an
application actually open now for this
fall's application cycle we have access
to about half a billion dollars of a
financial aid from our universities and
we'd like to
you know harvests more of America's
latent Italian form areas that we
haven't reached earlier I'd say to your
listeners to make sure that your local
high school actually uses our
application in that only about a third
of the high schools in the country have
handed applications in and then for
people who would like to create their
only intervention let's say for Lauren
come kids wanting to do medicine science
with low income women nerville and
computer from the south or almost any
interest they can even reach out to me
to me directly and I on your blog you
can feel free to put my email address if
you like to okay wonderful and would you
like to give that out now or would you
prefer Thurston yeah
yeah it's Michael at Westbridge org
great and buy prizes you mean people
could offer some type of what what might
a prize look like yeah it's really on it
could be it could be non-monetary like
we'd like to say you know have a bucket
a leadership award it like the White
House or something but it can be as
simple as we win a pilot for Native
Americans where we give away a twenty
laptops cooking the actual university
application up to the apprised
application and we grew from having only
34 applicants one year to over 250 the
year after that so for everyone
listening I just want to really
encourage you I I am very very I have a
very very tight filter tightness filter
when it comes to working with nonprofits
and this this one is worth your time so
I would just encourage you to look at it
forget about the label nonprofit as an
intervention that can better humanity as
as Reed mentioned this is this is one of
the rare gems out there in my opinion
and you know other organizations that
I've worked with like DonorsChoose for
instance Charles best is a huge fan of
Quest bridge and he said the first thing
he said to me when I mentioned a few
years ago that Mike
you and I connected he said that is an
excellent choice that is an awesome
choice
so people check out quest bridge org and
you can reach Michael if you'd like to
discuss collaborating in some way
Michael at quest bridge org so I'll just
ask one more question guys it'll take
one or two minutes and that is let's
let's let's start with you Michael if
you could have one billboard anywhere
that said anything what would it say and
where would it be I probably people do
what you do Tim
pick something you're afraid of every
day and and kind of go after it and I'd
put that I'm kind enough people's a way
to work I suppose what about yourself
Reid well this is kind of a i funny
reflex but just something I would
thinking about recently I think I would
take the billboard in Washington DC I
think I would target Congress people and
I say have you worked with someone
across the aisle today because what
matters is not partisan conflict but how
do we govern our country to actually
have a better future here here
definitely last question guys do you
have any ask or requests for my audience
Reid we can start with you and then
where can people find you online where
can they pin you on social networks etc
well the social networks it's very easy
there's this service that maybe a few
people have heard of called LinkedIn you
know findable there I'd say two things
one is you know I would also echo the
fact that quest bridge is a scale way of
of changing the world for the better of
actually making us more of the you know
kind of for us in the US the American
Dream in terms of the ability for for
talented low-income youth to actually
you know live in a meritocracy so I
think it's awesome and whatever way you
can support whether it's contributing or
helping or you know pointing the right
talented young kid at it is all great
and then the second is you know last
year I published a book called the
Alliance your audience tends to be
highly literate not a surprise given you
and so in as much as they're thinking
about how is the nature of employment
and how is the nature of of the
relationship between an employee and a
company changing I think it might be
something that could stimulate a few
thoughts definitely and I have a copy of
that book at home and SF everybody
highly worth the read so highly
recommended there well gentlemen this
this has been wonderful I've really
enjoyed the conversation and for
everybody listening I will put
everything we discussed
in the show notes so we'll have links to
quest bridge the book recommendations
and so on just go to 4-hour workweek com
all spelled out and click on podcast to
find that and guys I really appreciate
you making the time this was this was a
lot of fun and I have pages and pages of
notes just for myself Tim always a
pleasure and always an honor thank you
for the competition
alright guys until next time thank you
and everyone else until next time thank
you for listening
this episode is brought to you by
99designs your one-stop shop for all
things graphic design related I have
used 99 designs for everything from
banner ads to book covers including
sketches and mock-ups that led to the
4-hour body which later became number
one New York Times number one Wall
Street Journal and the brainstorming a
lot of it took place with designers from
around the world and here's how it works
whether you need a t-shirt a business
card a website and app thumbnail
whatever it might be you submit that
project and designers from around the
world will send you sketches and
mock-ups and designs you choose your
favorite and you have an original that
you love or you get your money back it's
that straightforward and many of you who
are listening have already used it and
created some amazing things that I'll be
sharing in the future but in the
meantime if you want to see some of my
competitions some of the book covers as
well as get a free $99 upgrade go to
99designs dot-com forward slash Tim
that's 99designs com forward slash temp
this episode is brought to you by a new
sponsor so listen up folks this is a
good one because have you ever wanted to
be as powerful as a bullet wearing ninja
from a 1980s movie or as flamboyant as
big gay al Big Al in South Park or as
sleek as a black panther in the Amazon
on the hunt well there's greatness
because I've been testing this product
that you wrap around your genitals and
it makes you feel like a superhero and
it is called biondi's I've spent the
last two to three weeks traveling with
underwear from these guys and they are
comfy I got to tell you it feels like a
Geisha is giving your groin a hug and
it's not just for dudes but if you go to
meet undies comm forward slash Tim
that's ma Eun di es comp or slash Tim
you can see all of the underwear that
I've been wearing there's some pretty
ridiculous ones and I will also
highlight my favorite you'll probably be
able to guess which it is these are the
rare made from micro mud doll which is
extruded from Austrian Beachwood trees
in the Alps yes
fancy and it's 2 times softer than
cotton scientifically tested is in the
kalibata method developed in Kyoto
you know those Japanese very crafty and
I will say a few things number one if
you go to me on DS comm forward slash
Tim you get to see all of the
spectacular underwear that I've been
wearing and I am a bit of an underwear
connoisseur socks fashion sense with
sweatpants not so much underwear I
understand so check them out and if you
go to Mandy's comm /tm you will also be
able to see lots of hot ladies wearing
me undies female underwear and that's
just a lot of goodness for both the men
and the women out there so check it out
me undies comm forward slash Tim I love
these underwear and I am going to be
packing tonight probably six to twelve
pair to take with you to Australia
they're great
check them out the undies comm forward
slash tip and until next time thank you
for listening